am tag liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
herzlich willkommen in der
bundespressekonferenz herzlich
willkommen unseren gästen der
bundesministerin für bildung und
forschung anja karliczek dem
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn und
dem präsident des robert koch institutes
an professor lothar wieler
es geht um die aktuelle corona lage und
die forschungsförderung die ministerin
und der minister sind direkt aus dem
kabinett zu uns gekommen allen die uns
an den bildschirmen verfolgen sage ich
dass sie eine bundespressekonferenz
sehen die bundespressekonferenz ist eine
regierungsunabhängige organisation von
journalistinnen und journalisten
wir versuchen dass hier alle fragen
gestellt werden können und alle fragen
natürlich auch antwortet werden
dem sender phoenix danke ich herzlich
für die unterstützung bei der
gebärdendolmetscherin die können sie
dort sehen aber auch nur dort
frau ministerin carlitscheck sie haben
das volks-ja fielen dann probiert hast
ja lieber jens lieber herr professor
wieder meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren ich freue mich sehr dass ich
heute mit meinem kollegen entspannen ein
weiteres wichtiges förderprogramm zur
welt 19 bekannt geben darf auch wenn er
gott sei dank im moment das
infektionsgeschehen zurückgeht und
einzelheiten werden wir bestimmt gleich
aufhören aber die pandemie ist eben
nicht vorbei und auch die folgen werden
uns natürlich noch eine weile
beschäftigen
und dennoch finde ich sollten wir aber
auch immer doch in den mittelpunkt
stellen wir sind in der bekämpfung der
korona pandemie schon weit gekommen und
deswegen möchte ich an dieser stelle
auch ein ein bürgerinnen und bürgern für
ihre unterstützung und auch durch ihr
verhalten dazu beigetragen zu haben
herzlich dank sagen aber es ist
natürlich in besonderer weise und das
sage ich natürlich als
bundesforschungsministerin nicht ganz
ohne stolz
ein verdienst der wissenschaft dass wir
jetzt schon so weit sind und gerade
viele wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler von weltruf die eben
auch bei uns hier in deutschland tätig
sind
ich will an dieser stelle auch ganz
besonders das ehepaar türe che sahin
nennen die mit ihrem unternehmen
dafür gesorgt haben dass aus deutschland
heraus hier in europa der erste
zugelassene impfstoff entwickelt worden
ist und dass wir heute in der eindämmung
der pandemie so weit sind und zwar auch
zu diesem zeitpunkt schon ist eben ein
ganz wesentlicher verdienst der des
ehepaars to riches sahin sie haben denke
ich doch alles geleistet und jeder cent
wir haben im letzten jahr ja intensiv
unterstützung gegeben jeder cent an
forschungsförderung hat sich ausgezahlt
und dann diese erfolge beim impfstoff
wollen wir jetzt auch mit dem medikament
gegen kuwait 19 ansetzen denn neben
impfen und auch den verstärkten testen
brauchen wir dringend sichere und
wirksame medikamente
sie sind neben den impfstoffen
entscheidend um auch der pandemie in den
nächsten jahren den schrecken zu nehmen
wir werden diese medikamente benötigen
auch wenn ein großteil der menschen
geimpft ist
denn wir müssen davon ausgehen dass das
virus uns noch länger begleiten wird
und nicht jeder kann und will geimpft
werden und nicht bei allen geimpften
wird ein vollständiger schutz vor
erkrankungen erreicht sein und deswegen
treiben wir den medikamentenforschung
mit ganz gezielten förderprogrammen
voran und bislang stehen eben nur wenige
medikamente zur behandlung von kogit 19
zur verfügung
zu nennen sind dexamethason als
generellen entzündungshemmer reserviert
das ursprünglich mal gegen das ebola
virus entwickelt worden ist und auch
verschiedene monoklonalen antikörper und
zeller koreakrieges die eu
gesundheitskommissarin hat ja die
zulassung von drei weiteren medikamenten
auch in diesem jahr angekündigt wir
sehen grundsätzliches geht voran
das bundesforschungsministerium fördert
seit ausbruch der pandemie die deutsche
arzneimittelforschung bei der
praktischen und bei der klinischen
entwicklung ihrer arzneimittelkandidaten
und ich sage das ganz bewusst weil die
frage ist häufig gestellt worden das ist
damals in den aufregungen der ersten
zeit glaube ich ein wenig untergegangen
wir sind schon anfang märz letzten
jahres hingegangen mit einer ersten
förderrichtlinie aus unserem haus die
medikamentenentwicklung in deutschland
zu
damals ging es erstmal darum ein
besseres verständnis für das virus zu
bekommen auf der anderen seite eben
zugelassene medikamente zu testen
auf wirksamkeit gegen kuwait 19 und auch
schon ganz frühzeitig die
grundlagenforschung für neue medikamente
gegen kuwait 19 anzuregen
einige vorhaben in der
medikamentenentwicklung haben in den
letzten monaten jetzt bereits
grundlegende vorklinischen
entwicklungsphase abschließen können und
sie stehen jetzt auf dem sprung in die
klinische entwicklung ihrer
arzneimittelkandidaten und hier setzt
unsere zweite förderrichtlinie an auf
die man sich zu beginn dieses jahres
seit januar bewerben konnte und konkret
geht es bei dieser zweiten
förderrichtlinien darum die entwicklung
in den klinischen phasen 1 und 2 bis 2 b
zu unterstützen
und wenn man diese phasen erfolgreich
abschließt dann ist es eben auch bereits
möglich für das medikament eine
vorläufige zulassung zu beantragen
die auswahl dieser zweiten
förderrichtlinie in höhe von 50
millionen euro ist so gut wie
abgeschlossen
die förderung läuft jetzt weit an ich
will ihnen eine kleine beispiele nennen
was für ansätze da gewählt worden sind
ein ansatz zb beruht auf einem kleinen
chemischen molekülen sogenannten kinase
inhibitor welche faktoren der
körperzelle adressiert und das ist eben
die frage für die virusvermehrung dieses
wirkt so die bisherigen hoffnungen in
den forschungsergebnissen sowohl gegen
das virus als auch gegen eine
überschießende entzündungsreaktion ein
zweiter lichtblick sind verschiedene
monoklonale antikörper welche dann im
dienste des immunsystems stehen um mit
ihrer spezifischen struktur
neutralisieren auf das virus selbst
wirken können um es zu bremsen
aber es gibt eben auch andere antikörper
die gegen krankheits verstärkende
signalstoffe gerichtet sind und auch
virus infizierte störungen im körper
dämpfen und dadurch zum beispiel auch
organfunktionen wieder verbessern
wir sehen an vielen vorhaben wie
vielfältig eben auch die ansatzpunkte
sind und das ist auch der grund warum
wir immer wieder gucken gibt es
vielversprechende entwicklungen mit
denen wir helfen
können und so sitzen entspannt ich heute
hier und setzen nun mit einem weiteren
förderprogramm zur entwicklung der
versorgungs nahen cupid 19 arzneimittel
in höhe von 300 millionen an diesmal
eben zusammen mit dem bmg jeweils um
versorgungs nahe forschung an dieser
stelle schon geht und im kommenden
freitag wird eben der voerder aufruf
jetzt im bundesanzeiger veröffentlicht
wer heute schon mal schauen will
veröffentlicht auf unserer seite schon
die förderrichtlinie dass man gucken
kann was drin steht
mit dem neuen förderprogramm werden wir
nun die späte klinische entwicklung bis
zur zulassung fördern also das ist in
die phase 2b und drei um einen
fundierten wirksamkeitsnachweis bis zur
zulassung zu ermöglichen
und außerdem können dann im rahmen der
förderung herstellungskapazitäten am
standort deutschland aufgebaut und
ausgeweitet werden und damit wollen wir
die markteinführung der
arzneimittelkandidaten an dieser stelle
beschleunigen antragsberechtigt sind auf
der einen seite unternehmen die eine
betriebsstätte in deutschland haben aber
eben auch kleine verbünde aus
universitäten außeruniversitären
forschungseinrichtungen in mit
entsprechender unternehmensbeteiligung
die können auch zum zuge kommen die
anträge können ab freitag dann bis zum
juni vorgelegt werden für maximal
anderthalb jahre und die
förderentscheidung selbst treffen wir
gemeinsam mit dem gesundheitsministerium
basierend auf den empfehlungen eines
expertengremiums und in diesem experten
gremium sitzen dann vertreter aus
pharmawirtschaft klinischer forschung
und auch den regulierungsbehörden
dadurch sind wir auch so schnell weil
wir immer alle gleich mit an bord haben
unser ziel mit diesem neuen programm ist
es alle entwicklungsprozesse abzudecken
und die programme wie wir jetzt
gestartet haben setzen aufeinander auf
indem sie an ganz verschiedenen
entwicklungsstadien ansetzen und das ist
ein wichtiger punkt denn wir holen damit
die arzneimittel entwickler genau dort
an den innovations- phasen ab wo sie
gerade stehen
und so geben wir damit gewähr dass wir
sicher gehen möglichst vielen für erfolg
versprechen den ideen am ende eine
chance zu geben
handlungen von patientinnen und
patienten eingesetzt zu werden wir haben
aber auch festgestellt
das ist auch wichtig dass es eben doch
bei manchen noch ein bisschen zeit
brauchen bis die philippinische phase
starten können und deswegen planen wir
auch das förderprogramm der früheren
klinischen phasen was wir ja januar
schon mal aufgelegt haben in diesem
sommer noch einmal neu aufzulegen weil
wir glauben dass dann noch weitere viel
versprechende kandidaten so weit sind
dass sie so ein förderprogramm gut
brauchen können aber gerade in der
späten klinischen phase und deswegen
setzen wir heute hier und haben die 300
millionen im gepäck ist eine forderung
wichtig denn die entwicklung von
arzneimitteln ist auf der einen seite
äußerst kostenintensiv und kann häufig
und gerade eben von kleineren
unternehmen nicht alleine getragen
werden
im austausch mit fachexperten und
fachexperten wurde nämlich gerade an
dieser stelle ein erhöhter förderbedarf
bei der herstellung versorgungs nahe
arzneimittel deutlich für die produktion
zwischen absehbarer zulassung und
markteinführung der herstellungsprozess
komplex und mehr niedrig und es müssen
eben frühzeitig herstellungskapazitäten
aufgebaut werden das haben wir ja auch
bei den impfstoffen gesehen dass das
eine herausforderung ist so schnell an
dieser stelle so beweglich zu sein und
deswegen geht es auch verlässliche
vereinbarungen mit zulieferern schon
frühzeitig treffen zu können und da
springen wir dann in die bresche denn
all das haben wir bei dieser
förderrichtlinie berücksichtigt eines
will ich auch tun ich will an dieser
stelle eine erwartungshaltung dass wir
deswegen morgen medikamente haben ein
wenig dämpfen denn die entwicklung von
arzneimitteln dauert in der regel jahre
und nicht monate manchmal sogar
jahrzehnte und wichtig ist ja auch dass
wir eben nicht davon ausgehen können
dass es eine wunderpille geben kann
sondern dass es je nach schwere und
stadium der erkrankung ganz
unterschiedliche therapien geben muss
die erkenntnisse die wir bisher haben
über diese erkrankung zeigen dass es
verschiedene ansätze und auch eine große
bandbreite an verschiedenen
krankheitsphasen und verläufen gibt und
dafür brauchen wir dann eben immer die
passende therapie und deswegen ist es
auch gut dass wir so vielfältig
in die förderung einsteigen herzlichen
dank für die gute zusammenarbeit dass
wir diese förderrichtlinie heute auf den
weg bringen können und damit eben auch
die herstellung und die entwicklungen in
den blick nehmen ist glaube ich ein
wichtiger punkt der liebe vw-fahrers
liebe frau kollegin die wir an ja meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren heute
geht es unter anderem auch mit blick auf
die forschungsförderung um die frage wie
wir besser und dauerhaft mit diesem
virus werden leben können leben auch
lernen können das virus wird bleiben
die frage ist erstens bekommen wir ist
unter kontrolle
dazu hilft vor allem auch das impfen
lernen wir auch immer besser selbst mit
wären übrigens das gilt über dieses
virus hinaus im alltag umzugehen auch in
der frage von alltags regeln und zum
dritten ebene für diejenigen die
tatsächlich an group 19 weiter auch
erkranken werden bei einigen können aus
medizinischen gründen nicht geimpft
werden im moment auch wegen des alters
nicht geimpft werden bei einigen ganz
wenigen aber die situation gibt es im
auch kommt es trotz impfung auch zu
einer erkrankung ist es wichtig eben
auch therapien zu haben um einen
unterschied zu machen
wichtig ist übrigens eine ist um das
auch noch mal zu sagen eigentlich haben
wir genau eine wahl entweder man wird
geimpft oder man wird infiziert
im laufe seines lebens jeder wird diese
dieses virus sozusagen er leben im
wahrsten sinne des wortes und ich würde
im zweifel immer empfehlen die immunität
durch impfung erreichen zu wollen und
nicht durch das durchmachen der
infektion möglicherweise der erkrankung
wir haben das bundesministerium für
gesundheit vom gesetzgeber vom deutschen
bundestag 300 millionen euro zur
verfügung bekommen für dieses
forschungsprogramm und ich bin dankbar
dass wir das gemeinsam zwischen
forschungs und gesundheitsministerium
wenn du nach ausgestalten in den
richtlinien auch mit der erfahrung die
da es in der forschungsförderung und in
der abwicklung eines solchen programm
ist aber auch in der zusammenführung das
ist ja gerade deutlich geworden mit den
vorherigen programmen und den feurigen
programm stufen also eine
arzneimittelentwicklung hat ja
verschiedene stufen
und hier geht es jetzt vor allem auch um
größere größenordnung deswegen geht es
mit 300 millionen
euro auch um mehr geld weil da studien
zum teil damit tausenden von probanden
in dieser phase gemacht werden müssen
die ersten studien klinische
studienphase 1 haben manchmal nur eine
handvoll von probanden und nach hinten
ganz natürlich immer mehr
es geht darum auch möglicherweise schon
produktionskapazitäten vorzubereiten und
anzureizen und damit ist die dimension
insgesamt eine größere so dass das
sozusagen passend zur abfolge auch die
forschungsprogramme und förderprogramme
dann geschnitten sind und wir damit auch
aus deutschland heraus da beitrag
leisten wollen wie bei den impfstoffen
ein coupé 19 therapie zu erreichen das
impfen nimmt der pandemie und der
infektion den schrecken eine
wirkungsvolle therapie nimmt der chor
mit 19 erkrankung den schrecken
vielleicht wenn sie gestatten noch zwei
weitere themen ansprechen zum zweiten
kabinett gerade die einreise verordnung
des bundes beschlossen ist es erstmalig
eine einheitliche verordnung für
einreise vorgaben und für quarantäne
vorgaben mit dem vierten
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz hat die
bundesregierung erstmals die möglichkeit
auch einheitlich für deutschland
quarantäne vorgaben bei der einreise zu
machen und nicht 16 verschiedene wir
haben in dieser verordnung auch
erstmalig wie angekündigt für genesene
und geimpfte andere regelung als für
noch nicht geimpfte und genesene nämlich
das ist unter normalen umständen jemand
der vollständig geimpft ist nicht in
quarantäne muss und auch die test
erfordernisse wegfallen außer das ist
wichtig weil virusvarianten gebieten
mutations gebieten wo wir ein besonderes
risiko haben
grundsätzlich gilt auch weiterhin hermia
risikogebiete hoch incidents gebiete mit
starken infektionsgeschehen um
virusvarianten gebiete quarantäne
erfordernisse bei nicht geimpften
personen nur bei risikogebieten und hoch
incidents gebeten kann man durch eine
testung die quarantäne abkürzen bei
hochrisiko hoch incidents gebieten nach
frühestens fünf tagen bei risikogebieten
direkt nach einreise und das ist eine
wichtige neuerung bei risikogebieten
die im moment nicht selten ein sehr
vergleichbares infektionsgeschehen auch
zu unserem eigenen haben kann direkt
nach der einreise durch einen negativ
testung die nachgewiesen werden muss die
aktiv nachgewiesen werden muss
die aber auch und online hochgeladen
werden kann bei der einreise anmeldung
die quarantäne verkürzt werden was
insbesondere auch etwa wie manche eltern
die mit kindern reisen wollen wo die
eltern möglicherweise schon geimpft sind
dann für die kinder auch eine lösung ist
dann durch testen die quarantäne
entsprechend zu verkürzen bei risiko
gebieten zu lage allgemein ist mir
einmal mehr wichtig gerade in dieser
woche wo wir alle aus einem wochenende
kommen nicht in ganz deutschland aber
doch in weiten teilen deutschlands mit
gutem wetter und spürbarer guter laune
und zuversicht und in ein verlängertes
wochenende gehen mit christi himmelfahrt
morgen dass wir jetzt zuversichtlich
sind dass die gute laune zurückkehrt ist
ja erst mal gut und die zuversicht aber
wir müssen jetzt sehr aufpassen dass die
zuversicht nicht zu übermut wird und
dass wir nicht allzu viel dann jetzt
haben an kontakten und an lockerungen
weil die frage wie juli und august
werden die entscheidet sich nicht heute
die inzidenz zahlen von letzter woche
sind nicht entscheidend für die frage
wie der sommer wird sondern das
entscheidet sich in den nächsten vier
fünf sechs wochen
ob wir im sommer tatsächlich insgesamt
eine bessere lage haben werden können
die infektionszahlen sinken die
intensivstation sehen moment eine
entlastung die positiv rate bei den
testungen geht zurück also die alles
geht in die richtige richtung aber wir
haben gerade lockerungen auf einem
niveau wo andere länder trotz höherer
impfungen noch nicht gelockert haben und
deswegen kann ich nur dafür werben dass
mit viel umsicht zu machen wo gelockert
wird unter 100 vor allem draußen dinge
möglich zu machen wie etwa die
außengastronomie draußen ist das risiko
um den faktor 10 mindestens um den
faktor 10 geringer als drinnen und
daneben auch möglicherweise wenn es um
auch sport oder anderes geht vor allem
die dinge auf draußen zu konzentrieren
bei drinnen noch zurückhaltender zu sein
und ist vor allem auch
verknüpfen mit test erfordernissen wir
haben jetzt eine test infrastruktur die
das möglich macht sehr breit und sehr
ausgebaut
und wenn man das verknüpften starker
fokus auf aktivitäten draußen und sowohl
draußen wie drinnen etwa bei
einzelhandels öffnungen mit test
erfordernissen dann gibt das zusätzliche
sicherheit in dieser jetzt in dieser
phase wo es um die richtige balance geht
zwischen zuversicht und umsicht und
vorsicht
und da kann jeder einzelne weiteren
beitrag zu leisten wir haben die zahlen
runter gebracht weil so viele bereit
sind und waren im alltag für sich einmal
mehr auch in dieser dritten welle ein
unterschied zu machen kontakte zu
reduzieren sich impfen zu lassen ob das
macht eben einen entscheidenden
unterschied wie wir sehen oder sich
testen zu lassen und zu dieser balance
von zuversicht und vorsicht gehört
übrigens auch das ist eine bereitschaft
braucht auf allen politischen ebenen vor
ort in den ländern und im bund dann wenn
die instanzen wieder steigen sollten in
einem bestimmten bereich in einem
landkreis in einer stadt in einer region
dann auch sehr schnell wieder
beschränkungen einzuführen und nicht zu
warten bis es dann wieder richtig hoch
gestiegen ist das heißt also diese
bereitschaft jetzt wahrzunehmen dass es
gut läuft und daraus schlussfolgerungen
und lockerungen abzuleiten muss gepaart
sein mit der bereitschaft im fall der
fälle dann aber auch mögliche
lockerungen wieder zurückzunehmen ein
letztes zum tag der pflegenden der heute
er ist an diesem tag an diesem mittwoch
unser ziel war es immer in dieser
pandemie das gesundheitswesen vor
überlastung zu schützen das ist uns auch
gelungen
aber es hat und gibt es heute sehr
starke belastung und die gibt es vor
allem auch im bereich der pflege für die
pflegekräfte die aufopferungsvoll und
wir haben ja in einer der letzten
pressekonferenzen dass auch hier noch
mal erlebt aber auch eindrücklich ja in
vielen anderen berichten von den
intensivstationen aus den kliniken sich
für ihre patientinnen und patienten
einsetzen
die an vielen stellen bis an den rand
der erschöpfung und die grenzen ihrer
leistungsfähigkeit
und psychisch arbeiten und das eben auch
machen um gemeinsam mit uns gut durch
diese pandemie zu kommen und gerade am
tag der pflegenden ist glaube ich
wichtig sich zu erinnern aufeinander
aufzupassen das machen wir für uns das
machen wir für unsere lieben das machen
wir aber auch um gerade die pflegenden
zu entlasten und weitere belastung zu
vermeiden
dazu gehören auch die richtigen
rahmenbedingungen und nach den
äußerungen der letzten tage auch der
kolleginnen und kollegen aus dem
kabinett bin ich sehr zuversichtlich
dass wir etwa für die frage der besseren
bezahlung von altenpflegekräften auch
noch vor dem sommer in den
parlamentarischen wochen die uns noch
verbleiben ein kompromiss finden der
sicherstellt dass es regelhaft eine
tarif bezahlung oder tarife ähnliche
bezahlung zumindest auch in allen
bereichen der altenpflege gibt so wie
das in der krankenpflege auch der fall
ist so dass aus dem tag der pflegenden
tatsächlich nicht nur worte sondern auch
taten folgen danke ministerpräsident
guten morgen meine damen und herren die
fallzahlen in deutschland gehen weiter
zurück momentan liegt die inzidenz bei
107 800.000 einwohnern und inzidenz
sinken in allen altersgruppen und sie
sinken auch in allen bundesländern und
gleichzeitig werden immer mehr menschen
gegen kuwait 19 und ein drittel der
menschen in deutschland hat inzwischen
mindestens eine impfdosis erhalten und
vollständig geimpft ist etwa einer von
zehn also zehn prozent das sind
erfreuliche entwicklung wir sind auf
einem guten weg
und bei aller zuversicht dürfen wir aber
eines bitte nicht vergessen diese
pandemie ist ja nicht vorbei die
instanzen gehen zwar zurück sie sind
aber immer noch zu hoch in deutschland
mittlerweile haben rund 190 landkreise
eine 7 tages inzidenz von unter 100
erreicht dass es toll ja aber die
mehrzahl landkreise die restlichen ca
220 liegen eben immer noch über 1
wir sehen auch dass vor allem die
jüngeren immer noch sehr stark betroffen
sind besonders schulkinder und junge
erwachsene bei diesen altersgruppen
beobachten wir die höchsten instanzen
mit weiterhin über 150 kowitz fällen pro
100.000 seit ende der osterferien haben
zb die ausbrüche in den schulen auch wie
erwartet wieder rasch zugenommen
trotz eines leichten rückgangs sind auch
die intensivstation nach wie vor sehr
belastet und nach wie vor werden auch
jeden tag viele todesfälle an das robert
koch institut gemeldet
pro woche versterben weiterhin in
unserem land über 1000 menschen
und 19 im zusammenhang mit dieser
infektion also die situation ist weiter
ernst
wenn aber der rückläufige trend bei den
fallzahlen weiter anhält wenn wir es
gemeinsam schaffen die ansteckung weiter
zu reduzieren
dann wird sich in den nächsten wochen
hoffentlich auch die situation auf den
intensivstationen weiter entspannen und
auch die zahl der todesfälle wird dann
hoffentlich zurückgehen es dauert ja
immer ein paar wochen bis die positiven
effekte sich dann auch dort zeigen und
darum möchte ich meine bitte wiederholen
wir haben in den letzten wochen zusammen
wirklich sehr sehr viel erreicht und
lassen sie uns diesen weg bitte
weitergehen und hier auch nicht
nachlassen dafür müssen wir eben weiter
alle diese werkzeuge benutzten wie wir
seit vielen wochen ihnen immer wieder
vorstellen und die uns zur pandemie zur
verfügung stehen das sind natürlich die
impfungen das ist das mächtigste
werkzeug gar keine frage aber genauso
wichtig kontakte reduzieren
abstand halten hygieneregeln atemmasken
also mund nasen schutz und lüften weil
wir wissen dass in innenräumen die
ansteckungsgefahr größer ist dass die
aerosole verdünnt werden
bitte nehmen sie testangebote war und
bei erkältungssymptomen bleiben die auch
bitte zu hause und wenden sich dann halt
an ihren arzt und wie gesagt wir haben
jetzt viele werkzeuge das mächtigste ist
die impfung und im moment und das ist
der punkt reicht die impfquote alleine
eben noch nicht aus
um zu verhindern dass sich das virus in
der bevölkerung ausbreitet zurzeit sind
gut 33 prozent der menschen mindestens
einmal geimpft und zehn prozent
vollständig geimpft das sagt sich
bereits aber bis wir das virus unter
kontrolle haben bisher weitgehend auf
maßnahmen und regeln verzichten können
muss der anteil der immunen menschen in
der bevölkerung entweder durch eine
vollständige impfung und ich glaube das
ist der bessere weg den wählen alle dies
können hoffe ich oder durch eine
durchgemachte impfung durchgemachte
infektion plus eine impfung bei deutlich
über 80 prozent zahlen wir möchten nicht
diese 80 prozent erreichen dadurch dass
wir uns infizieren mit dem virus sondern
wir möchten dass das durch impfung
geschickt und wenn wir uns die daten
nach altersgruppen anschauen dann sehen
wir auch dass bei den über 80-jährigen
tatsächlich schon mehr als 70 prozent
vollständig geimpft sind also sieben von
zehn über 80 sind vollständig geimpft
aber drei von zehn eben auch nicht
und bei den 70 bis 19 jahren sind sie
etwa zehn prozent die vollständig
geimpften und bei den 60 bis 69 jährigen
sind es etwa 6 prozent also da ist noch
viel luft nach oben da müssen noch sehr
viele menschen geimpft werden bei den
unter 59 jährigen sind es nur rund 5
prozent die vollständig geimpft sind
also um es auf den punkt zu bringen das
wird noch einige zeit dauern und bis
dahin bleiben im moment die anderen
werkzeuge ganz essentiell und darum ohne
sie und wenn wir zu früh öffnen würde
sich das virus wieder verbreiten das ist
ganz klar das haben wir nun lange genug
oft genug in allen ländern der welt und
auch in deutschland gesehen also sagen
wir uns nun dafür sorgen dafür dass auf
den letzten metern nicht noch zu vielen
unnötigen krankheitsfällen kommt zu
schweren krankheitsfällen zu todesfällen
und auch zu den langzeitfolgen
ich wiederhole dass auch immer gerne es
gibt longo fit das ist eine
langzeitfolge die wir noch nicht ganz
verstehen die aber bis zu zehn prozent
etwa nach unserem heutigen wissen
betrifft zehn prozent wir sind in
deutschland ja weit mehr als drei
millionen infizierte also ist eine große
zahl lassen sie uns bitte nicht
ungeduldig werden und viel zu viele
schritte auf einmal geht das haben wir
den letzten wochen zusammen erreicht
lassen sie uns diesen weg konsequent
weitergehen
dankeschön vielen dank herr professor
lila
wir haben einen strengen zeitplan heute
in der bundespressekonferenz wir haben
jetzt eine gute halbe stunde nur ich
habe hier schon ungefähr 20
wortmeldungen vorliegen und mein ehrgeiz
wäre ist dass wir die durch kriegen und
das klappt auch wenn sich alle kurz und
strafe fassen und ich glaube es mir auch
schon geschafft in der vergangenheit die
erste frage geht an den kollegen dort
[Musik]
zuerst einmal ist ja eines wichtig dass
wir nicht einen digitalen impfpass haben
nur für deutschland sondern vernetzt
europäisch und weltweit und die auch da
müssen wir ja früher wäre besser wenn
ich dafür aber schauen wir doch mal was
wir gerade dabei sind umzusetzen wir
setzen da hat einen weltweiten maßstab
als europäische union haben uns geeinigt
mit standards mit schnittstellen mit
beckhams gateways wie das alles
technisch heißt einen digitalen impfpass
zu entwickeln
in den europäischen ländern der ganzen
eu funktioniert und kompatibel ist und
wenn uns das gelingt für die eu jetzt in
den nächsten wochen dann wären wir damit
im zweifel ein weltmaßstab setzen weil
wir die erste region auf der welt sind
der das überhaupt gelingt nicht nur eine
nationale lösung zu haben sondern eine
die international anschlussfähig ist das
haben nicht mal die usa weil wir ja
immer schauen was ist in den usa sehr in
den usa gibt es teilweise zwischen den
bundesstaaten in vielen bereichen sehr
unterschiedliche lösungen und deswegen
haben wir sehr darauf gesetzt dass es
europäisch vernetzt mit europäischen
auch einheitlichen vorgaben dieser
entwicklung gibt und wenn wir das jetzt
richtig machen werden wir der benchmark
für die welt akzeptiert wenn sie sagen
das hätte auch ein paar wochen früher
sein können aber sie müssen eben auch
sehen die entwicklung von apps durch die
bundesrepublik deutschland hat sehr hohe
anforderungen an datenschutz und
datensicherheit berechtigterweise sie
haben bei der korona waren es nicht bis
heute nicht ein datenschutz und ein
datensicherheits thema gehabt die krone
waren app ja die hat auch zwei drei
wochen länger gedauert als in anderen
ländern
sie hat bis heute nicht ein datenschutz
und nicht ein datensicherheits thema von
jeglicher relevanz gehabt
das ist bei anderen apps anders die
aufseher in der öffentlichen diskussion
waren und so wollen wir es bei diesem
digitalen impfpass auch halten
rund um den jahreswechsel und seit ende
januar gibt es die ersten in einem
gremium dessen name ist ein fachgremium
mir gerade auf europäischer ebene das
den namen habe ich nicht aber ende
januar gab es dort die ersten standards
standard setzungen so und die ersten
vorgaben und dann haben wir begonnen
auch weiter in der umsetzung und handeln
selbst zügig auch um so weiter klar war
wohin die reise geht dann ja dass auch
beauftragt ich will nur dazu sagen ich
hätte die debatte zum
immunitätsausschuss von letztem jahr
angesprochen haben ich erinner debatte
noch sehr gut wir hatten sogar in einem
gesetzentwurf schon regelung vorgesehen
und mussten ja miteinander feststellen
dass die gesellschaftliche debatte
jedenfalls noch nicht so weit war das
schon alle einen regelungsbedarf gesehen
haben
aus diesem grund haben wir es ja damals
wieder rausgenommen ich habe zwei fragen
die sich auch auf das es den nachweis
beziehen
das ist einfach von frank jordaans von
ap da geht er fragt halten sie es für
medizinisch ratsam imk nachweise mit
sputnik und sie nowak mit den von
impfstoffen die von der iaea also der
europäischen gesundheitsbehörde
zugelassen sind gleich zu stellen wenn
es zb um reisen geht und der kollege
garcia vom spanischen fernsehen fragt
ist ab heute die tests schlecht für
einreisende aus nicht risikogebieten wie
mallorca aufgehoben
also zuerst einmal für und aus mallorca
würde ich sagen gibt es fast nur
sinnvoll den flugweg aussage macht es
ganz anders aber jedenfalls für
flugreisen gilt generell aus dem ausland
weiterhin die testpflicht gilt ja egal
für die frage wie das gebiet eingestuft
ist alle auslands also aus dem ausland
nach deutschland kommenden flugreise
verkehrsteilnehmer müssen ein negatives
testergebnis vor boarding zeigen dass
bleibt weiterhin gültig und gültig
bleibt oder anders was sich verändert
ist das bei risikogebieten
die entsprechend qualifiziert sind und
auf der seite des robert-koch-instituts
haben wir ja virusvarianten gebete hoch
inzidenz gebete risikogebiete bei
risikogebieten nach einer reise durch
aktives nachweisen eines aktuellen
negativ tests die quarantäne verkürzt
werden kann aber nicht einfach auf
eigene entscheidung sondern durch
aktives nachweisen eines negativ tests
haben die frage von herrn jordaans also
erst einmal auch unsere verordnung zur
einreise stellt ab auf in der eu
zugelassene impfstoffe die bei denen man
von der quarantäne ausgenommen sein wird
die frage ob auch andere nicht in der eu
zugelassene impfstoffe gleich
qualifiziert sind oder nicht muss aus
meiner sicht geprüft werden idealerweise
das müssen wir europäisch tatsächlich
noch vereinbaren ansonsten wäre das für
uns paul-ehrlich-institut und robert
koch-institut wir müssen ja schauen wir
müssen sehen die vero auch die eu
zulassung aber auch der hauptfokus auch
unsere forschungsförderung übrigens
letztes jahr war vermeidet die impfung
die kurve 19 erkrankung das ist bis
jetzt der hauptfokus gewesen aller
aktivitäten und kriterien und jetzt
haben wir einen stärkeren fokus gott sei
dank können wir den haben weil wir etwa
bei biontech ag cbf den impfstoffen
sehen sie vermeiden nicht nur eine kurve
19 erkrankungen sie reduzieren auch
massiv das infektionsrisiko das war ja
gar nicht so erwartbar und dann müssen
die ausländischen also was heißt ja auch
die nicht-europäischen so ist besser für
mich die nicht europäisch zugelassenen
impfstoffe nachweisen dass sehen ähnlich
großem umfang infektionsrisiken
reduzieren wenn das der fall ist habe
ich kein problem mit der gleichstellung
aber ich möchte einen nachweis
grundsätzlich gibt es eine sehr sehr
hohe positive resonanz das ist ja nicht
nur ein vorschlag von deutschland auch
die französische regierung hat einen
ähnlichen vorschlag gemacht wir werden
unter portugiesischen vorsitz in der
nächsten woche ein ministerrat haben der
sich auch mit dieser frage beschäftigt
wir nennen das den portfolio ansatz also
eben nicht nur auf einen impfstoff zu
setzen auch für 2022 23 sondern auf
mehrere welcher jetzt konkret ist
natürlich jetzt verhandlungssache
also ist er weiterhin die kommission
auch in gesprächen in verhandlungen auch
mit anderen herstellern wie mit den
herstellern entwicklern anderer
technologien wir sind übrigens auch noch
aktiv in verhandlungen also mit wir
meine ich jetzt die europäische union
mit nowaks unter anderem auch mit wein
eva werden gespräche geführt also es
gibt durchaus noch zusätzliche impfstoff
hersteller und entwickler übrigens auch
mit nochmal ganz neuen technologie gehen
etwa proteinbasierter oder tod
impfstoffe die bis jetzt noch gar nicht
im portfolio sind und ich finde einfach
sehr wichtig so sehr ich auch von hoher
zuversicht und freude darüber bin was
biontech weiterentwickelt haben und ich
sehr dankbar dafür bin dass wir diesen
großen 1,8 milliarden dosen vertrag
haben für 22 23 mutationen kinder
impfstoff alles mit berücksichtigt so
wichtig finde ich es doch gleichzeitig
auch dass wir nicht nur auf einsetzen
eine nachfrage
sogar nicht einmal erstmals für weg bis
hierhin und gar keine zulassung
ich freue mich jetzt erstmal sehr auf
den zeitpunkt der hoffentlich bald
erreicht wird das für eine zulassung
auch bei cure weg haben und dann ist es
wie gegen eine verhandlungssache weil es
geht ja nicht darum irgendwie vertrag zu
schließen was uns sehr wichtig war auch
nach den erfahrungen des letzten jahres
ist dass die frage der genauen
lieferdaten der abfolge der
vertragsstrafen bei nicht rechtzeitiger
lieferung der frage wie ist das mit
anderen mutations angepassten
impfstoffen die frage wie ist das mit
der dosierung bei kinder impfstoffen
dass wir also in einem solchen vertrag
all die parameter die wichtig sind schon
von vornherein noch klarer geregelt
haben als das im letzten sommer war und
dann liegt sie auch an den herstellern
ob sie bereit sind sich darauf
einzulassen bei m rna herstellern fallen
mir allerdings stand der pegel gerade
nur drei ein moderner koubek und eine
frage von port holstein zu diesem thema
von apotheke adhoc wie bewerten sie ist
aus der eu komplett auf biotech setzt
also vor der zulassung von glivec das ja
preiswerter ist und an dieser 1,8
millionen dosen bestellt hat hält der
bund pro jahr
der bund steht hier hält der bund an der
beteiligung am kuhberg fest
beziehungsweise war dies ein fehler
also zuerst einmal nicht noch einmal ich
finde es sehr gut und sehr wichtig dass
dieser vertrag mit beyond eckpfeiler
jetzt auch frühzeitig geschlossen ist
weil er volumen erster sicherheit für
uns 2022/23 für alles was noch kommen
kann weil er gleichzeitig auch ein
signal ist an die forscher weiter zu
forschen etwa mit blick auf mutationen
war der drittens auch den standort
deutschland stärkt das ist ein
nebenaspekt aber einer den ein als
deutscher minister durchaus auch
erfreuen darf aber ich wir haben immer
gesagt und so sieht das auch die
kommission wie auch die mitgliedstaaten
wir setzen nicht nur auf ein
vertragspartner und die weiteren
verhandlungen finden jetzt statt was die
beteiligung des bundes ein chorwerk
angeht dürfte das bis jetzt eine der
mehrwert steigende beteiligung gewesen
seien im vergleich zu anderen
beteiligungen die es in anderen krisen
gegeben hat in den letzten zehn jahren
das ist aber nur ein aspekt an der
stelle entscheidend ist natürlich auch
die zulassung die qualität des produktes
die weitere forschung mir ist wichtig
dass wir mit koubek bei montech das
machen wir auch in der task-force
impfstoffproduktion und anderen edc
vielen anderen übrigens jetzt habe ich
angefangen es gibt ganz viele
impfstoffhersteller und vorstufen
produzenten in deutschland dass wir mit
denen darüber reden wie wir kapazitäten
aufbauen und vorhalten auch über die
pandemie hinaus dass wir so wie bei
elektrizität bei strom
reservekapazitäten haben auch bezahlen
und dann im fall der fälle ganz schnell
hochfahren können und dafür werden wir
partner finden müssen aus meiner sicht
die produktion in deutschland haben er
fällt auf
wir wissen schon her fällt auf dass wir
hier die regel haben eine frage eine
nachfrage
wir starten in der zweiten hälfte des
zweiten quartals die zweite hälfte des
zweiten quartals fängt nächster woche an
und endet ende juni und ich kann ihnen
das jetzt auf einen tag nicht sagen weil
das ist bei digitalen projekten und
entwicklungen so dass nicht zuletzt
durch die modellprojekte die es ja auch
geben soll und die testregionen oder
tests die gemacht werden sich ja immer
erkenntnisse ergeben können die noch mal
ein paar tage überarbeitung brauchen
deswegen sehen wenn sieben nach dass ich
noch kein datum nennen kann
aber wir wissen von welcher wichtigen
bedeutung dass für viele ist die das
gerne digital dokumentieren möchten sind
mit hochdruck daran
aber ich möchte schon eins zu sagen weil
ich jetzt irgendwo sinngemäß sah dass
einige sagten jetzt können wir wieder
nicht reisen weil der digitale pass
nicht da ist mit verlaub das ist
natürlich nicht so denn mit dem papier
nachweis sind die dinge ist übrigens der
gelbe impfpass ist internationaler
standard sind die dinge genau so möglich
aber natürlich ist es im jahr 2021 im
zweifel schöner nicht papier mit sich
herum tragen zu müssen aber die frage
was man kann hängt nicht von digital
oder analog ab dann geht es weiter mit
herrn reitschuster alle die jetzt noch
fragen hier online senden noch ich wenig
wort kommen ich über mein bestes
übrigens die europäische lösung kam mir
gerade wieder wurde auf einem
europäischen rat sogar im januar
beschlossen und war der startpunkt was
die frage kinder jugendliche angeht gibt
es ja wieder zwei verschiedene über drei
verschiedene aspekte das erste ist die
frage der zulassung entdeckt pfizer
haben für die europäische union eine
zulassung beantragt die keine notfall
zulassung wird sondern wenn dann die
zulassungs zulassung wie wir sie jetzt
schon kennen das wer mit
unterschiedlichen ansatz als die
vereinigten staaten in der frage der
zulassung
wenn es eine zulassung geben sollte wo
wir stand heute denke ich optimistisch
sein können weiß nie dann wird es ein
interesse an dieser impfung geben bei
zwölf- bis 18-jährigen wie bei den
eltern
am ende ist es ja eine freiwillige
entscheidung eine freiwillige
entscheidung der eltern oder ab einem
bestimmten alter auch der jugendlichen
selbst ob sie sich impfen lassen wollen
oder nicht
und dann auch eine entscheidung die man
ja gemeinsam mit dem impfen den arzt
trifft das gilt aber für jede impfung
egal ob ich 16 bin oder 60 ist eine
individuelle entscheidung ob seine
entscheidung mit dem arzt
wann und wie in zug ankommen eine
empfehlung der ständigen impfkommission
zum beispiel wann sie besonders
angezeigt ist aber die zulassung ist ja
davon unberührt sind zwei verschiedene
aspekte und ich nehme jedenfalls war ich
glaube so ist die debatte auch in der
mit blick auf schulen es geht übrigens
hier nicht um urlaub wie ich heute
morgen gelesen habe es geht darum dass
wir in einer pandemie sind und in einer
pandemie ist um die frage geht ja wie
ist der individuelle schutz aber
natürlich auch wie ist der gruppen und
beide argumente eine rolle spielen in
der
in der abwägung und wir gerade in dieser
pandemie erlebt haben wie hart es ist
für kinder wie für eltern wenn schule
und die aktivität miteinander nicht so
stattfinden können weil die schule vor
allem ein risiko für die älteren ist
nämlich dadurch dass in einer
drehscheibe sozusagen die wären dann in
alle familien getragen werden und all
diese aspekte spielen eine rolle
mir ist nur eines wichtig ist bleibt
natürlich unbedingt bei einer
freiwilligen impfung seine entscheidung
der eltern mit den kindern und den
ärzten
wenn es eine entsprechende zulassung
gibt und entsprechende empfehlungen zum
impfen fließen dann damit ein
aber die entscheidung bleibt trotzdem
bei den eltern und den kindern eine
zusatzfrage indem ich sage das ist keine
verpflichtende impfung geben würden ich
würde das gern noch einmal unter einem
punkt ergänzen wir kriegen jetzt dann
hoffentlich bald den im die
impfmöglichkeit für zwölf- bis
15-jährige und wir wissen dass die
studien für die kleineren noch länger
dauern und auch unter diesem
gesichtspunkt möchte ich sehr dafür
werben denn ein wichtiger punkt ist ja
dass er auch weitgehend vor infektionen
schützt und da natürlich die älteren
kinder dann häufig auch noch jüngere
geschwister haben ist das in griff
kriegen einer panel ii natürlich gerade
dort gegeben oder ist viel schwieriger
wenn eben wenig junge menschen sich
impfen das also je mehr menschen sich
impfen lassen
je besser schützen wir die die wir auch
noch nicht impfen können und das ist
natürlich für die frage wieviel
schulbetrieb ist denn unter ganz
normalen bedingungen oder unter relativ
normalen bedingungen ab dem herbst
möglich ein ganz ganz wesentlicher punkt
das müssen wir glaube ich viel
deutlicher sagen und ein zweiter punkt
ist longo wird kann auch junge menschen
betreffen und man weiß es noch nicht wir
werden im nächsten es noch mal explizit
mit einer förderung beschäftigen um
longo wird nochmal besser besser zu
entschlüsseln worauf es zurück zu führen
ist aber auch die erkenntnisse dauern
natürlich eine zeit
und jeder der sich ansteckt ist
potenziell auch jemand der langfristig
schäden davonträgt
insofern kann man unter normalen
umständen das impfen sehr empfehlen ich
habe noch zwei fragen zu jüngern online
von basil wegener von dpa sind an den
bieler unteren sparen aber vielleicht
kommt das auch bisschen strafen sind
impfungen bei kindern mit bier und sekt
obwohl so heikel dass es für
individuelle beratung in den dafür in
die welt individuelle beratung in den
kinderarztpraxen braucht und ist der
zeitplan sommerferien überambitioniert
und die andere frage kommt von herrn
heinrich also zuerst einmal ist es immer
eine individuelle entscheidung des zu
impfenden und bei jemand der
minderjährig oder nicht
entscheidungsfähig ist dann eben in
diesem fall der eltern auch ob geimpft
wird oder nicht ich krieg übrigens
ziemlich viel de-mails post nachfragen
von besorgten eltern die sich sehr eine
impfung wünschen nicht zuletzt auch bei
kindern mit vorerkrankungen
es gibt nicht wenige eltern die große
sorgen haben um ihre kinder die
möglicherweise eine maske haben oder
ganz andere vorerkrankungen haben die
sich sehr für die sicherheit zum schutz
ihrer kinder ein entsprechendes
impfangebot wünschen
und insofern ist das dann eben die
individuelle entscheidung das zitat
überambitioniert stammt der vom
vorsitzenden der kinder und jugendärzte
in fischbach fischbach hat mir gerade
anfang dieser woche ein brief
geschrieben wie wichtig es ist die
kinder- und jugendärzte einzubeziehen in
die kampagne da das nie anders gedacht
war
wir sprechen auch die tage nochmals
darüber machen wir das auch so aber die
kinder und jugendärzte wie die
kassenärztliche vereinigung auch heute
haben ja gesagt dass das miteinander zu
stemmen ist wenn man es gut vorbereitet
und deswegen haben wir ja mit den
ländern bereits letzte woche vereinbart
dass sich in den ländern jetzt schon
gedanken gemacht werden soll
für den fall einer zulassung wie man ein
solches impfangebot tatsächlich eben bis
zum ende der sommerferien ende august in
manchen bundesländern sind ein wenig
früher ich komme aus nrw für mich fällt
ende und sommerferien und ende august
immerhin etwa zusammen aber ich weiß
dass einige bundesländer auch andere
daten haben aber jedenfalls sind die
länder ja schon im denken wie man dieses
angebot am besten auch machen und
umsetzen kann immer vorbehaltlich einer
zulassung so dass ich da eigentlich
optimistisch bin dass das gelingen kann
und sie das ergänzen herr professor
wiener oder die zweite frage ist
zwischen hab ich dir gesehen
das geht nämlich um die im um die
verwirrung dies nach astrazeneca gab und
die frage von herrn heinrich von watson
ist mit unter bezug auf minderjährige
wie gewährleisten sie das nach einer
freigabe von bartek weiter für
minderjährige ähnliche verwirrungen um
möglichen nebenwirkungen auftreten wie
bei astrazeneca ach so wie ich das
vermeide ja also wir leisten sie
tatsächlich also ich persönlich habe
habe keine verwirrung wahrgenommen
sondern was ich wahrnehme ist das dass
wir in deutschland ein wirklich
ausgezeichnetes system haben wo wir
nebenwirkungen erfassen das heißt ein
system pharmakovigilanz nennt man das in
jedem fall beim paul-ehrlich-institut
sind wieder froh dass wir diese
nebenwirkungen erfassen dass wir
transparent darüber berichten und das
ist dann ein wissensstand der sich
ergibt und daraus ergeben sich dann
entsprechende änderungen von empfehlung
zum beispiel von der ständigen
impfkommission
wir werden ja sehen was geschehen wird
werden das weiter beobachten und dann
wird das ausgewertet und ich kann es nur
noch mal sagen wir haben einen impf wir
haben einen virus dieses virus wird uns
nicht mehr verlassen dieses virus wird
auf dauer jeden deutschen infizieren
da gibt es also der nicht geschützt ist
durch eine impfung das wird auf dauer so
sein dass wir uns oft endemisch und wir
sollten froh sein wenn wir ihm stoffe
haben und die impfstoffe die bei uns
zugelassen sind wir haben ja nicht nur
die europäische zulassung sondern wir
haben ja auch das paul-ehrlich-institut
das nochmal drüber schau diesen sicher
und wirksam
und dann schauen wir das an und dann
wird es ja auch in zukunft
wahrscheinlich weitere impfstoffe geben
die vielleicht noch weiterentwickelt
werden
das heißt also ich bin hier glücklich
dass wir eine institution haben die da
drauf schaut kritisch ist und das wird
dann öffentlich diskutiert und wenn es
für verwirrung sorgt dann tut mir das
leid aber das ist wissenstand dass
wissenschaft in die wird so gut wie
möglich kommuniziert mehr kann ich dazu
nicht sagen
also wenn wir kommen dann sind wir immer
noch ganz am anfang wir entwickeln
gerade eine förderrichtlinie dafür dass
man longo witt besser entschlüsseln kann
worauf es zurückzuführen ist aber da man
darüber ja noch keine erkenntnisse hat
muss man einfach das in die kategorie
wir müssen vorsichtig bleiben einordnen
weil man eben heute noch nicht sagen
kann den es trifft und weil also warum
es den auch überhaupt trifft und ob auch
das thema langfristigkeit ist ja noch
etwas was relativ ist wir kennen dieses
virus jetzt hier in diesem land seit gut
einem jahr
und deswegen kann man auch heute noch
nicht sagen bleibt es bei dieser großen
zahl von zehn prozent die wir im moment
an erkenntnisstand haben oder ist das
jetzt etwas was ich dann noch einmal
verkleinert
über den lauf der zeit deswegen machen
wir uns jetzt auf den weg und wollen das
ganze besser entschlüsseln und besser
besser in angriff nehmen aber solange
man keine gesicherten erkenntnisse
darüber hat kann man auch jedem nur
empfehlen sich entweder impfen zu lassen
wenn er sich impfen lassen kann oder
eben vorsichtig zu bleiben und er wieder
dass er gerade sehr schön gesagt wir
kommen aus einer pandemie dann hinterher
in die situation dass es langfristig
eben bei uns bleibt dieses virus und
damit müssen wir uns einfach auseinander
setzen das ist ja der grund warum wir
heute hier sitzen und sagen wir brauchen
medikamente weil dieses virus eben nicht
wieder weg geht aber eben im moment kann
man nur jedem empfehlen vorsichtig zu
bleiben jede ansteckung birgt eben
potenziell das risiko dass man eben
langfristige schäden davonträgt und die
sind ja eben sehr unterschiedlich bei
manchen ist das ist einmal irgendeine
organ krankheit die sich dann dadurch
ergibt und bei anderen ist es eben auch
diese dieses jahr hat sie diese
schlafkrankheit erschöpfung ja genau
diese und das ist etwas was natürlich
lebens beeinträchtigend wirken kann
es gibt noch dazu eine frage von bologna
4 aus von rtv slovenia sie fragt nach
dem rehabilitationszentrum in
mecklenburg vorpommern gibt es eins wo
solche patienten betreut wird planen sie
in naher zukunft weitere zentren zu
eröffnen
also generell haben die
rehabilitationseinrichtungen nicht alle
aber viele in deutschland sich auch auf
19 patienten eingestellt ich war selbst
im august in ostwestfalen da gibt es so
viele mit bart
ich glaube es war beiden dem springer
jedenfalls in soko orte im drehort
es gibt viele reha einrichtung nicht nur
in mecklenburg vorpommern
ich habe das natürlich auch sehr
eindrucksvoll deswegen kann ich da
gerade vor augen wie ich dazu besuch war
mit münster noch zehn fragen mit dem
schnell mit patienten gesprochen habt
und einer war 60 tage unter beratung und
sagte mir 130 ersparen ich werde nie
wieder so ein leben leben können wie
vorher weil diese bleibenden schäden
da sind und dafür die reha maßnahmen zu
entwickeln passgenau auf diese
erkrankung das passiert in den reha
einrichtung mit der wissenschaft und das
tut das in mecklenburg vorpommern aber
nicht nur essen
also wir geben mit unserer
forschungsförderung eine unterstützung
die grundsätzlich darauf angelegt ist
dass sie einen gesellschaftlichen nutzen
hat und zwar für alle sondern dann ist
ja die frage wie geht man damit um und
ich will vielleicht noch drei sätze zu
der frage patent sagen
privatwirtschaftliche investitionen wie
wir sie zum beispiel über viele jahre
bei den impfstoffherstellern gesehen
haben die jetzt auch zum zuge kommen wie
zum beispiel bei montech oder eben auch
bei cure weg wenn wir diese sicherheit
zukünftig nicht geben dass wir dann eben
auch die patente
das würden dass wir an diesen patenten
festhalten und dass wir eben damit
vertrauen und sicherheit für
privatwirtschaftliche hochrisiko
investitionen geben dann werden sie
nicht stattfinden und es gibt ein gutes
beispiel wo dann überhaupt keine
forschung gerade in diesem
medikamentenbereich stattgefunden hat
weil es keine solche patent oder keine
sicherheit für patente gab das ist das
land italien
die haben viele viele jahre nur generika
hergestellt und jetzt sind seit einigen
jahren gibt es eben auch diese
sicherheit für patente und diesen schutz
und seitdem entwickelt sich auch in dem
land eine community die sich eben mit
der entwicklung und erforschung von
medikamenten und eben auch impfstoffen
beschäftigt und da sieht man wie wichtig
das ist dass man auf der einen seite
stabile rahmenbedingungen und sicherheit
gibt gerade eben dann auch bei der frage
um die patente auf der anderen seite ist
es natürlich war wenn es eben ein
allgemeingut werden soll und dann muss
man aber von vornherein eben das auch
ein stück weit mehr in staatliche hände
nehmen und weil wir eben das problem
haben dass wir in deutschland viel
grundlagenforschung betreiben aber
häufig doch über dieses man nennt das
teil des todes nicht wegkommen dass wir
in diesem bereich sagen ja da wollen wir
zukünftig mehr tun das gilt eben auch
für die frage
und antibiotikaresistenzen auch da das
ist am ende ja etwas was ich privat
wirtschaftlich nicht lohnen will wenn es
um eine reserve antibiotika geht und das
sind fragestellungen denen werden wir
uns in zukunft mit der europäischen
union über die über eine förderagentur
und nähern und in dieser förderagentur
legen wir dann natürlich auch fest unter
was für konditionen daneben auch die
diese entwicklungspotenziale dann
genutzt werden können
aber wenn wir heute in etwas eingreifen
aus der vergangenheit zerstören wir
damit vertrauen und damit im grunde
einen ganzen markt der sich heute sehr
sehr gut entwickelt dass wir heute so
schnell an einen impfstoff gekommen sind
hat damit zu tun dass eben über viele
jahre dieser entwicklung auch aus der
privatwirtschaft gefordert worden ist
und stabile rahmenbedingungen sind
gerade bei hochrisiko investitionen
etwas was lebensnotwendig ist um da
wirklich auch am ball zu bleiben
es ist aber nicht es ist aber am ende
nicht die frage der freigabe eines
patentes sondern am ende der frage von
im von produktionskapazitäten und die
produktionskapazitäten sind im moment zu
gering schneller die ganze welt impfen
zu können und ich glaube wir müssen uns
auf das echte problem konzentrieren und
nicht ein anderes problem aufwerfen was
am ende ist einmal die lösung nicht
näherbringen wird wo wir aber gerade
eben lernen dass diese
privatwirtschaftlichen investitionen ein
großer teil dessen sind was uns jetzt so
schnell in die lage versetzt hat man
muss man muss nochmal überlegen diese
frage nach amerika
die wird seit 20 jahren geforscht im
grunde haben wir genau an dieser stelle
sogar ein stück weit glück gehabt dass
die weltweite forschung so weit war dass
sie jetzt mit ich sag mal im
zusätzlichen booster daneben auch so
schnell impfstoff herstellen konnte wie
weit ist doch den größten gefallen den
sich china gerade machen können ist alle
patente die in europa entwickelt wurden
frei zu geben mache ich meine wir müssen
einfach irgendwas noch leben in diesem
land damit wir anderen helfen können und
damit wir forschen können damit wir
forschungsförderung machen können
braucht erstmal wertschöpfung in
deutschland die steuergelder fallen ja
nicht irgendwo vom himmel die werden
erwirtschaftet bevor man fördern kann
das eine hängt mit dem anderen zusammen
und das ziel teilen wir ja also ich
zumindest nämlich ihren fragen das ziel
das wird das teilen dass wir eine
versorgung für die welt wollen gerade
auch in dieser pandemie mit impfstoffen
und therapeutika
die frage ist nur was ist der weg dahin
so dass man selbst stark genug bleibt um
auch in zukunft solche sachen und solche
medikamente und impfstoffe entwickeln zu
können übrigens wenn ich gerade über die
kapazitäten gesprochen habe die wir
fördern wollen als vorhalte kapazitäten
was ich mir sehr wünschen würde und
wofür ich werbe bei diesem konzept ist
dass wir das nicht nur für deutschland
verhalten wenn es nochmal ebola geben
sollte also was ähnliches wie ebola in
einer anderen region der welt wir
relativ wenig betroffen möchte ich nicht
noch mal dass es zehn 15 jahre dauern
muss bis es endlich einen impfstoff gibt
der verfügbar ist und ich möchte dass
wir kapazitäten in deutschland und
europa aufbauen aus dieser pandemie
heraus die auch bei viruserkrankungen
ganz anderen teilen der welt die für
diese region ein riesenproblem sind
einfach helfen kann weil wir hier
kapazitäten haben zu helfen
ich möchte jetzt noch eine ganz schnelle
schlussrunde machen um den kollegen die
von anfang an gefragt haben hier schon
die möglichkeit zu geben noch eine
antwort zu bekommen
rasmus buchsteiner von der pioneer fragt
sie herr sparen ab welchen incidents
fährt während sie dafür die vom
bundestag festgestellte notlage ende
juni auslaufen zu lassen oder gibt es
etwas das stand heute unbedingt für eine
verlängerung spricht ich denke es ist
klug zum jetzigen zeitpunkt mitte mai
sich noch nicht zu der frage zu
verhalten wie ende juni die dinge sind
klar ist eines das gesetz läuft am 30
juni aus das ist aktuelle rechtslage und
wenn sie wenn wir alle gemeinsam
weiterhin diese beiden parameter halten
inzidenz sinken impfen steigt dann ja
münster polizisten befragt
sie war selbst das sind jetzt auch
irgendwie zwei fragen also ja ich habe
da eine frage zugelassen
jetzt macht das ist augen ist okay wir
diskutieren das später soll ich anfangen
es gibt bei kindern und jugendlichen und
bei der frage um bildung immer um einen
schwierigen abwägungsprozess wie lange
können wir bildungseinrichtungen offen
halten und dann müssen wir eben unter
gesundheits gesichtspunkten eben dafür
sorgen dass sie geschlossen werden und
dass der unterricht dann im distanz oder
wenn es noch geht im wechsel unterricht
stattfindet und das ist kein einfacher
prozess und da gibt es nicht richtig und
falsch sondern da gibt es eben
irgendwann eine obergrenze wo man sagt
das können wir an dieser stelle nicht
mehr verantworten
und deswegen ist auf diese art und weise
in der notbremse dann die 165
entschieden worden wir haben ja den
referentenentwurf mit 200 erstmal in die
diskussion gegeben und dann hat man auch
aus dem deutschen bundestag heraus
gesagt also 165 ist die situation mit
der wir uns gerade auseinandersetzen und
das scheint uns schon hoch genug zu sein
und man muss glaube ich auch immer
wissen je höher wir aussteigen aus dem
schulbetrieb umso länger dauert es bis
wir wieder einsteigen können in den
schulbetrieb und dass es auch ein
abwägungsprozess der immer stattfinden
muss ich werbe sehr dafür mit guten
hygiene konzepten sich darauf
vorbereitet vorzubereiten das jetzt und
eben auch im herbst für die
grundschulkinder das relativ normaler
regelbetrieb möglich gemacht werden kann
da kann das testen zu beitragen da kann
auch das impfen im umfeld dazu beitragen
ich habe es eben gesagt für die älteren
geschwister wenn sie jüngere geschwister
haben das sind alles fragen die kann man
immer nur im konzept und in einer
gesamtheit betrachten man kann nicht die
einzelne zahl in den mittelpunkt stellen
ich glaube dann kommt man nicht zum ziel
man muss die frage testen impfen und
hygiene konzepte immer wieder in einen
vernünftigen abwägungsprozess und die
notbremse ist eine bundes notbremse das
will ich an dieser stelle auch noch mal
betonen
eigentlich muss man darunter schon viele
maßnahmen treffen und dafür zu sorgen
dass wir gar nicht in so eine situation
hier sind so ein bisschen auf der
zielgrade die masten frage noch war noch
dass ich hab mir einfach noch fünf
fragen die hier schon seit einer stunde
der theoretisch zeit ihre frei
kabinettskollege entschuldigen wir
vielleicht nicht verdrängen also das
erste das erste zu der frage oder
generell war wild west vor 14 monaten
und ich bin selbst also hat er zwei
dimensionen moralisch ohne rechtliche
und das ausmaß von marischen und
zwischen gewinnen die wir jetzt
sozusagen deren wir gewahr werden die
wir jetzt nach und nach sehen können die
finde ich haben eine moralische
dimension die schwer akzeptabel finde da
wurde in einer notlage und zwar im
weltweiten notlage und zwar auch nicht
nur von einem unternehmen wenn wir
ehrlich sind ich meine warum haben
unternehmen die vorher noch nie in ihrem
leben irgendwas mit masken zu tun hatten
auf einmal angefangen sich mit masken zu
beschäftigen weil wild west war und weil
goldgräberstimmung war und alle
irgendwie das gefühl hatten wir können
jetzt die notsituation die das
gesundheitswesen hat in ganz europa und
auf der ganzen welt und die nur
situationen die die verantwortliche
politik hat dafür zu sorgen dass es
masken und schutzausrüstung gibt
ausnutzen mit menschen die ich
jedenfalls unanständig finde es toll
dass ist die moralische dimension die
andere ist die rechtliche gibt
geschlossene verträge die wir in der
damaligen situation unter den damaligen
umständen in schweren zeiten der not
geschlossen haben und die in diesem
konkreten fall den sie angesprochen
haben
noch im rechtsstreit sind und den phasen
wo wir noch im rechtsstreit sind schon
zum schutz unserer rechtsposition legen
wir die verträge nicht offen weil wir
erst mal gerne den rechtsstreit gewinnen
wollen
jetzt habe ich noch eine letzte frage
die strand gehen kann und dann müssen
wir umbauen
herr wie lange haben sie sorge dass sich
die dritte welle wieder aufschaukelt
fragt herr wegner von dem jahre also
[Musik]
wenn wir weiter und so verhalten wenn
wir weiter so vernünftig bleiben dann
können wir das natürlich unterbinden
aber ich kann immer nur wieder da ganz
klar sagen dass es eben nur gelingt wenn
wir weiter alle mitspielen
geht es ums impfen da geht es um die
hygiene regeln wir können es vermeiden
und wir müssen viele menschen impfen
insbesondere damit wir am ende des
jahres oder am ende des sommers im
herbst eben nicht wieder steigende
fallzahlen haben aber das gelingt eben
nur wenn wir weiter verstehen dass das
virus unterwegs ist und es immer noch
genug wohl nahe gibt die das virus
infizieren können
ich habe momentan überhaupt keine sorge
ich hoffe aber auch dass ich bis ende
des jahres auch keine sorge mehr haben
aber das hängt immer davon ab was
passiert und wie in vor allen dingen wir
selber das problem in den griff nehmen
lassen sie uns bitte nicht verniedlichen
wenn ich diskussion gehöre etwa dass man
sich lieber vier wochen früher und da
zum beispiel auf den großen eben schutz
verzichtet nur um vielleicht früher im
biergarten gehen zu können und einen
urlaub zu fahren
dann trägt das nicht dazu bei dass wir
den impfschutz erhöhen also wir müssen
schon sollten immer finde ich vor augen
haben was im letzten jahr geschehen ist
bitte lasst uns nicht vergessen wie
viele menschen das leben verloren haben
wegen dieser krankheit und bitte lasst
uns nicht vergessen dass die wichtigste
maßnahme ist die prävention sich nicht
anzustecken das können wir wir wissen
alles was wir dazu tun können um das
damit das nicht geschieht lassen sind
einfach weitermachen
vielen dank ich bitte alle kollegen die
hier jetzt nicht zu wort gekommen sind
aus dem online zugeschaut haben um
nachricht dass die fragen jetzt
leider nicht zu wort gekommen sind wir
sehen uns hier in dem sieben minuten
wieder zur novelle des
klimaschutzgesetzes ich danke unseren
gästen dass sie gekommen sind ja ich
habe hier alles ausgedehnt was geht und
ich bitte sie auch alle den saal zu
verlassen dass wir uns nicht noch auf
der treppe begegnen oder hat alle die
hier die den saal den hier noch bleiben
möchten ja den saal zu verlassen
ich danke schön entschuldigung für das
nächste währung halten